essentiellement ce qu'il faut faire
c'est d'électrifier nos entreprises donc
tu utilises plus de mazout de gaz de
pétrole toutes les énergies qui sont
non renouvelables là il va nous manquer
d'électricité falloir construire un demi
Hydro-Québec dans les prochaines années
c'est pas un petit mandat je vais
demander à Hydro-Québec de regarder la
possibilité de construire des nouveaux
barrages au Québec pour avoir d'énergie
propre additionnelle
le Québec a beaucoup d'ambition François
Legault veut faire du Québec un leader
nord-américain mondial même de
l'économie verte et de la réduction des
GS mais comment y arriver mon invité
pierre fitzgerbin ministre de l'économie
de l'innovation et de l'énergie qui
revient tout juste de la cop27 et pas
encore se décalage monsieur Facebook
bonsoir Monsieur en direct avec nous
précisions dans le fond sur l'idée
lancée par monsieur Legault et défenseur
de la campagne électorale il faudra
développer de nouvelles énergies au
Québec pour répondre à la demande
effectivement je pense qu'on te regarde
on est privilégié on a 99% de notre
énergie qui est renouvelable quand on
regarde par contre la demande puis on
veut des carboner nos industries on se
rappelle qui après 44% des GES qui
proviennent des transports et il y a
près 29% qui provient des industries ça
fait un chiffre important on veut tout
électrifier ce qu'on peut on ne veut pas
tout électrifier on va aller de
l'hydrogène sans probablement garder une
verre et aussi de la bio-énergie regarde
les besoins énergétiques renouvelables
et lorsque nous avons mais il faut
regarder comment on peut augmenter
l'offre qui va être
requise pour respecter nos engagements
on parle d'une urgence climatique et
d'une crise énergétique pour toutes
sortes de raisons les changements
climatiques
ont des effets désastrus même sur les
infrastructures
énergétiques ailleurs dans le monde ici
est-ce qu'on est on a vécu vers est-ce
qu'on est à l'abri d'une crise
énergétique au Québec
on a l'avantage d'être renouvelable
certains très gros avantage c'est un peu
paradoxe l'énergie opposé les
problématiques des émissions de GRS on
parle de 70% qui est causé
l'énergie donc nous au Québec qu'on peut
devenir la batterie de l'Amérique du
Nord où on peut résoudre ces enjeux-là
je pense qu'il faut il faut être prudent
sécurité je pense qu'on a les moyens
puis des différents moyens de l'éolien
on n'a pas encore maximiser on peut
optimiser nos barrages existants et
surtout on peut plus efficient efficace
au niveau de la consommation énergétique
quand on parle d'intermittence j'ai
parlé des gens de la Suède quand j'étais
à la cop27 puis on n'est pas
de votre séjour là-bas avez-vous appris
des choses intéressantes parce que les
gens disent ça sert à rien c'est
conférences il y a pas de consensus
revenez-vous avec dans vos bagages de
quelques solutions pour le Québec avec
une connaissance accrue j'étais là aussi
en reconnaissance parce que le côté
énergétique c'est nouveau pour moi
l'objectif j'avais été de d'accompagner
nos PME c'est le bon de mentionner qui a
beaucoup de PME du Québec qui ont des
solutions technologiques qui peuvent
être exportées à l'extérieur on parle de
brindback c'est un distribution des
édifice je pense j'ai ag7 qui peut de
diagnostiquer les émissions de méthane
alors il y a beaucoup des merkels qui
convertit des résidus de biomasse en
méthanol donc il y avait ça j'avais
aussi des rencontres avec des différents
gouvernements on parle de la Suède ils
sont très avancés sur l'Efficient sous
l'efficacité énergétique les
consommateurs regardent leur application
c'est une base continue savoir à quelle
heure ils vont partir de l'âge de la
vaisselle par exemple la modulation
climatique ça devient une bonne
politique économique est-ce que c'est
pour ça dans le fond que vous conjuguez
les deux mandats les deux fonctions
parce qu'il faut finalement donner ce
c'est payant de faire une bonne
politique
climatique je pense que oui je pense que
c'est pas important de dire que
l'énergie peut servir pour la création
de richesse collective et en même temps
nous aider à respecter nos engagements
audacieux quand même de réduire par
37.5%, ça fait 30 mégatonnes on doit
réduire de GES d'ici 230 donc les deux
peuvent cohabiter d'ailleurs je sais pas
c'est pour ça je pense que l'économie et
l'énergie vont de pair avec
l'environnement c'est avec mon collègue
Bono charrette à la COP 27 il y en a
beaucoup de projets conjoint on va faire
ensemble vous avez parlé de la batterie
du monde ou de l'Amérique pour le Québec
est-ce qu'on va devenir l'île Dorado de
certaines dans certains secteurs miniers
je pense qu'on a un plan économie verte
comme mon collègue va Jacques a mis de
l'avant très audacieux pour qu'on livre
la réduction 30 mégaton on va travailler
avec les pollueurs présentement qui
veulent nous autres aussi contribués à
ça on n'a pas le choix donc à
l'intérieur du Québec transport et
industrie je pense qu'on a vu qu'un très
précis mais pour les batteries donc on
va aider l'Amérique du Nord parce que le
Québec à cause de nos minérales
stratégiques on est capable de prendre
le minerai le lithium le nickel puis le
convertir dans des composants de
batterie donc on a un rôle très
important d'ailleurs on a fait des
annonces importantes de ce stade depuis
plusieurs mois
pour pour les batteries des amis
conducteurs là vous allez être pour tout
le monde il y en a pour tout le monde
est-ce que est-ce que le Canada selon
plus jamais sur la scène canadienne
est-ce que vous êtes à la remorque un
peu aussi de ce que le Canada doit faire
parce que vous aussi vous donner des
subventions pétrolières 100 millions me
disait monsieur Mousseau tout à l'heure
au Québec
mais quand même je pense que j'ai vu
monsieur Guilbaud monsieur champagne on
travaille
sur la filière batterie je pense que
vous avez deux trois collaborations chez
fédérales sur votre bien puis écoutez
les subventions ou pour attirer les
gardeurs de venir au Québec on a
évidemment l'électricité qui est un
avantage comparatif important quand on
regarde les autres province ou même des
États-Unis parce qu'ils sont plus guéris
que vert puis en plus on a quelques
instituts parce qu'on doit comme
gouvernement je pense stimuler la
demande puis aussi stimuler les
investissements pour respecter nos
engagements envers la liste du champ
magnétique vous avez parlé d'optimiser
les barrages électriques mais on le voit
au niveau de l'acceptabilité sociale les
barrages électriques nouveaux il y en
aurait pas d'acceptabilité sociale pour
ça vous n'êtes pas là-dedans
qu'est-ce que ce sont les besoins nous
avons énergétiques renouvelables alors
c'est sûr qu'on va regarder en premier
lieu les Alliés le maximiser je dois
aller j'ai vu des gens du Danemark le
Danemark qui ont 50% de la source
énergétique en éolien nous on n'est pas
là encore les des réseaux qu'il faut il
faut adresser quand même le transport
pour nous ça serait où nous parce que
les gens veulent pas d'avoir d'éoliennes
dans leur chambre
peut-être qu'on aurait un jour des
éoliennes près des usagers près des gens
qui ont besoin d'énergie renouvelables
combinées avec un certain modulation
hydroélectrique et qui peut être près
des usines pour les bicarbonés donc
évidemment c'est moins problématique
d'avoir des éoliens à faire mon que
m'avoir fait bonne question d'actualité
un espion pour les Chinois à
Hydro-Québec vous êtes responsable du
droit Québec parce qu'on va parler de la
géopolitique de l'énergie au cours de
cette émission vous serez plus à la
table à ce moment-là qu'est-ce que ça
peu importe le résultat judiciaire de sa
faire là mais quand même été il va
comparer demain le monsieur qu'est-ce
que ça qu'est-ce que ça signifie pour
vous de penser que c'est devenu au coeur
d'espionnage des questions d'énergie
sécurité énergétique de vie
excessivement important je pense que
personne ne fait la Bible de ça je suis
heureux de voir du Québec
découvert ça ils ont transféré le
dossier de GRC on verra les résultats
heureusement ce que je comprends on
parle des batteries on parle pas des
barrages évidemment quand on pense
une chose mais de jouer des barrages
d'autre chose la sécurité énergétique de
vie excessivement important c'est clair
qu'on a on a un ministre le bas sécurité
qui va prendre ça en charge pour
s'assurer qu'on fasse les bonnes les
bons investissements seriez-vous
d'accord qu'on élimine complètement pour
les derniers jours fossiles comme les
militants écologiste le plaid mais on
n'est pas pareil
la question c'est la transition
énergétique elle va durer combien de
temps dans combien de temps on va avoir
les jours renouvelables pour 100% de nos
besoins je pense qu'une période qui
requise mais à court terme
je pense qu'on va avoir d'autres
technologies qui vont arriver je pense
qu'il va falloir regarder comment est-ce
qu'on va capturer CO2 dans l'atmosphère
parce que on parle beaucoup de réduire
mais on a déjà des des dommages qui ont
été faites alors je pense que je pense
la technologie va avancer plus vite
comprendre qui va nous permettre
heureusement de soustraire j'ai passé
d'être allé avec nous en réaction de les
infections là-dessus sur le Québec dans
le fond et les priorités du Québec en
soins énergétique défi de la transition
est immense les c'est-à-dire que les
plans qui sont là présentement sont pas
alignés pour réduire le protège nos
objectifs de 2030 par exemple il faut
transformer tous les secteurs
l'utilisation d'énergie dans tous les
secteurs économiques et au Québec on a
quand même traîné on continue à traîner
donc on projette beaucoup en termes de
livraison par exemple dans le secteur du
transport on n'a pas livré encore c'est
très dur à livrer dans le secteur du
bâtiment où là on devrait être beaucoup
plus agressif on est encore à un pied
sur les fringues Hydro-Québec dit on
doit garder le garde naturel d'un
bâtiment donc c'est un frein et on parle
des secteurs industriels aussi où là on
va falloir des là c'est vraiment on n'a
pas les solutions maintenant
il faut vraiment de la réglementation
faut un accompagnement il faut une
direction c'est à dire qu'il faut des
gens sentent que si on va pas dans cette
direction là on se trompe et
présentement le message est pas encore
assez fort pour que tous les secteurs en
ligne parce que le gouvernement pas tout
gérer il faut envoyer un message assez
fort pour que le privé et les autres
acteurs embarquent aussi
ce que je retiens surtout de la position
du Québec en dans le domaine de la
tension énergétique c'est qu'on est des
grands gagnants de cette transition là
c'est clair qu'on a des atouts
absolument extraordinaires d'une part en
terme de pétrole on est des importateurs
donc on réduit notre déficit commercial
qui est important parce qu'on fait des
achats de pétrole de l'étranger
en fait on importe on importe en fait
essentiellement du Canada et des
États-Unis donc pour à peu près
moitié-moitié pas de chacune ces deux
pays là moi ce que je retiens c'est
qu'effectivement dans cette transition
on est absolument des grands gagnants
d'une part il faut installer des
énergies renouvelables qui prennent
quand même pas mal d'espace un an un
grand espace la transition énergétique
c'est une transition électrique on est
des champions d'électricité et la
transition énergétique va être très
consommatrice de minéraux or nous avons
aussi des minéraux au Québec donc
véritablement qu'on est positionné aussi
dans le domaine des batteries donc on a
tout à gagner les batteries oui
effectivement pour donc véhicule
électrique demande 6 fois plus de
minéraux qu'un véhicule à essence on a
des mines donc on est bien positionné ce
que je rajouterais pour finir là-dessus
c'est que il faut peut-être préparer la
population là-dessus il faut il faut le
dire que si on transit il va falloir
plus de lignes électriques puis il va
falloir aussi qu'on qu'on fasse
davantage d'exploitation minière donc je
pense que la population doit être
préparée à l'avance pour comprendre que
ça s'en vient dans les prochaines années
parce que le but cette émission ce soir
entre autres c'est de faire le lien
entre l'urgence climatique on lutte
contre les changements climatiques parce
que les énergies fossiles ont créé ce
désastre cette apocalypse que plusieurs
vives on peut aussi parler de la Garenne
qui a précipité les choses mais que ça
ça a un influent sur le type d'énergie
qu'on doit choisir et dans le fond la
question monsieur on est sur la bonne
voie au Québec on a fait ce qu'on fait
les bons choix mais on est sur la bonne
voie mais en même temps il y a un défi
puis j'ai trouvé ça intéressant quand
monsieur fait Gabin parlait de la notion
d'efficience parce que d'abord faut
viser aussi la sobriété c'est à dire que
au Québec au Canada on est dans les
grands producteurs mondiaux de gaz à
effet de serre et notre consommation
énergétique elle est problématique et au
Québec on est dans très longtemps on
était sur le frein puis on a fait des
modifications à la marge en ayant à
l'esprit que comme on est des faibles
émetteurs de gaz à effet de serre par
habitant par rapport à l'Amérique du
Nord mais on est déjà des bons élèves
alors que en ce moment on a aussi une
possibilité c'est à dire qu'on peut
entreprendre des changements
structurants on peut investir par
exemple investir massivement dans le
transport collectif mettre en place des
mesures éco fiscales c'est anormal qu'en
2022 presque en 2023 ont subvention des
voitures électriques alors qu'on a un
problème en ce
moment-là
enfin on préfère les deux c'est à dire
que on mène sur taxe au grand au
véhicule et les grosses cylindrez on met
une prime pour l'achat de la voiture
électrique et ça va faire en sorte que
c'est une politique à cou nul et les
milliards qu'on sauve parce qu'on parle
de milliards de dollars on parle de
subvention voiture électrique pourrait
aller dans la décarbonation de ce
secteur d'activité là qui émet 44% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre si je
peux me permettre juste me sucer encore
dans l'avenir on est déjà en retard on
est plus dans c'est un beau futur le
Québec ou une possibilité on n'arrête
pas de le dire et on le fait pas le
Québec pour réduire ses émissions de gaz
à effet de serre non plus d'ailleurs
augmenté mais le Québec on a dépensé des
milliards de dollars sans réussir à
faire les transformations qu'il faut on
gaspiller les milliards et on a besoin
d'une vraie stratégie qui nous amène
aujourd'hui quelque part et on ne sent
pas encore on a une volonté au moins on
a déplacé le mandat vers l'économie ce
qui est une bonne chose il reste à voir
comment on va être capable de livrer oui
tout un pari pour vous là Monsieur
comment réagissez-vous que c'est que
sont faites
pas qu'on a un plan vous avez mentionné
de sobriété je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
on peut faire avec ce que si on peut
tout électrifier de si on peut tous les
projets qui sont sur le bureau du
ministre
[Musique]